في السباق الرئاسي التركي اقتصر المشهد
على متنافسين رئيسيين هما الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان والمعارض كمالك الجدار
اوغلو لم يسبق ان اعتبر اوغلو محطه امال
المعارضه لكنه استطاع في النهايه الانتصار
بالقبول به كمرشح مشترك
التفاف لم يكن برضى الاغلبيه لكنه تم رغبه
من احزاب المعارضه بمواجهه اردوغان فاضطرت
لتوحيد صفوفها بتجمع سته احزاب تحت ما سمي
الطاوله السداسيه قبل ان تعيد تسميه
التحالفها تحالف الامه بقياده كالجدار
اوغلو صاحب الكتله الاكبر في البرلمان
وزعيم اكبر تحالف معارض كل جدار اوغلو لم
يفوز باي انتخابات ضد اردوغان منذ تولي
الاخير السلطه عام 2002 وواجهها ضغوطا
لثنيه عن الترشح للرئاسه رغم ذلك وجدت
المعارضه نفسها مضطره للقبول بالامر
الواقع لهدف واحد الاطاحه باردوغان تغيير
النظام السياسي
اقتصاديه مختلفه جذريا والاهم تبني نهج
مختلف كليا عنه في السياسه الخارجيه
اختياره كل جدار اوغلو مرشحا مشتركا بعد
خلافات عميقه قد يهدد بتفجير ازمات في اي
لحظه لذا سيجد كلجدار اوغلو نفسه امام
صراع قديم جديد فحلفاء اليوم هم اعداء
الامس القواعد الحزبيه المحافظه الداعمه
له السعاده الديمقراطيه والتقدم المستقبل
لديها عداء تاريخي ما احزاب اليسار ممثله
بحزب الشعب الجمهوري ورئيسه
اعدائه كالجدار اوغلو ليسوا فقط من احزاب
المعارضه لكنهم داخل حزبه خسارته
الانتخابات الرئاسيه قد تفجر غضبا عارما
وتتسبب بتفتت اصوات المعارضه خاصه وان
كلجدار اوغلو حاول ان يتقرب من المحافظين
رغم ايدولوجيا الحزب العلمانيه وضم
بقوائمه حلفاء السابق لاردوغان امر اثار
حفيظه قواعد حزبيه معار ضه واثار مخاوفه
من تاثير سلبي على المعدل التصويتي للحزب
وحظوظ الطاوله السداسيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات